okay
last thing on again every day we are
learning more about the insanity that
took place in the aftermath of the
november election and the in the lead-up
to the january 6 riots by now
you have no doubt heard if you've been
watching my show listening to the
podcast over the last year
all of the different ways in which they
were trying to get a hold of the fact
that joe biden won the election and that
they wanted to try to overturn it we've
talked about
uh 63 court filings all of which were
found to be without merit some to be
some were found where there was no
standing and many of them found to be
without merit we've learned about oh
mike pence is going to flip the election
somehow
either by something he does himself or
by sending it back to the states or you
know whatever the case may be
we also heard about declaring a national
emergency slash martial law
and there was this idea of seizing the
voting machines now what you do with the
voting machines once you seize them to
flip results
we can speculate we don't exactly know
but we now have reason to believe that
donald trump himself
who's shocked by this donald trump
himself was much more involved than
previously known in the plan to seize
those voting machines the new york times
breaking the story this week
trump had role
in weighing proposals to seize voting
machines
new accounts show that the former
president was more directly involved
than previously known in plans developed
by outside advisors to use national
security agencies to seek evidence of
fraud
six weeks after election day with his
hold on power slipping trump directed
giuliani to make a remarkable call trump
wanted him to ask dhs
if it could legally take control of
voting machines in key swing states
three people familiar with the matter
said remember that giuliani did so
calling the department's acting deputy
secretary who said he lacked the
authority to audit or impound the
machines
trump pressed giuliani to make the
inquiry after rejecting a separate
effort by his outside advisors to have
the pentagon take control of the
machines and the outreach to the
department of homeland security came not
long after trump in an oval office
meeting with then attorney general
william barr
raised the possibility of whether the
justice department could seize the
machines a previously undisclosed
suggestion
that mr barr immediately shot down
the new accounts show that trump was
more directly involved than previously
known in exploring these proposals to
seize voting machines as he grasped
unsuccessfully for evidence of fraud
that could help him reverse the 2020
election
right now
everyone's attention
is focused on the coup
and on election fraud and that makes
sense but look at how much we've learned
just about that and then think imagine
for a moment
how much other
um
crazy stuff was going on that we still
don't know anything about that will
likely be uncovered about the last four
years
it will probably take
conservatively another four years
to figure all of that out and it could
even take closer to eight to ten years
for it all to shake out in terms of its
repercussions
um it's very clear that they did attempt
a coup
but they seemed not that competent at it
they seemed as competent at
doing the coup
as they were at governing when donald
trump was president and it failed and it
became a sideshow but we can't write it
off and not worry
because as i said earlier desantis is a
more competent trump and that makes him
more dangerous
and these same techniques now with the
experience of 2020 knowing where the
holdups were knowing where it ended up
stalling
with a more competent person at the helm
could be a very dangerous proposition
and we've heard from
retired military generals who say if
trump had had the generals on his side
could have been a very different outcome
we've heard about um if there had been
more willingness in the house and
particularly the senate
to
uh attempt to reject or challenge some
of the results in a more serious way in
multiple states
it could have been a different outcome
now one more thought about this uh trump
role
in trying to seize voting machines
remember when william barr quit
seemingly out of the blue as attorney
general on december 23rd december 23rd
was the date of william barr's
resignation letter
did william barr
see the writing on the wall about what
was coming on january 6th maybe not
specifically but knowing this is
potentially bad and i don't want to be
associated with it and that's why he
abruptly quit because if you consider
the timing the meetings where the idea
of a national emergency was floated
the meetings where the question about
can we seize the voting machines all of
this stuff happened between the november
election
and december 23rd when william barr quit
and it seems plausible at least that
barr knew or suspected that something
insane was coming and decided to get the
hell out of there before it did doesn't
make barr any better of an attorney
general
it's just bar acting out of
self-interest the timing makes sense at
some point maybe we'll know for sure